[Music]
spring and mike florio pro football talk
live co-host football night in america
has done a wonderful job covering the
john gruden situation here
um
let's go back to friday mike we we got
the email what john gruden said about
demora smith the head of the nfl players
association and i was told at the time
it was a slow play that there were going
to be other emails about john coming out
but i'm wondering he was going into that
sunday game against the bears
figuring he's going to win he's going to
be 4-1 and maybe he's going to survive
this what did you hear on friday that
subsequently led to what happened last
night well as of friday there was
speculation on two different fronts some
people thought the league was determined
to get john gruden and that that's why
this one email out of 650 000 had been
leaked when it was and the other theory
was that the perfectly timed release of
that document given that at 6 pm eastern
on friday demoris smith was subject to a
vote by the nflpa board of player
representatives he needed to have
two-thirds of them say yes at a time
when it wasn't quite sure what was going
to happen there is a belief that the
league was trying to help him keep the
job because the league doesn't want a
new executive director he's been there
since 2009 they've gotten things done
and the league doesn't want that to
change so
there were two competing theories
and it's possible they're both accurate
that the reason for the first leak on
friday was to save damora smith
and then the other materials were sent
on friday to the raiders we didn't know
what they were
i think what the league was hoping would
happen is that gruden would decide to
walk away
or mark davis would decide to fire john
gruden without additional documents
being leaked and when gruden was defiant
when gruden showed no indication he was
going to do anything along the lines of
standing down that's when they leaked
more of these that's how it's being
played out and that's how people are
responding to it and it really is
stunning dan that
gruden
the the metaphor i've used is the first
torpedo hit the hull and he tried to fix
the damage when he knew damn well there
were other torpedoes in the water that's
when you abandoned ship but he waited
for the other ones to hit and i think it
made it much worse for him to have these
others come out monday i think if he
walks away friday saturday or sunday
these other ones don't come out yeah
that's what i was told but i'm also
curious about this and and we're all in
agreement that you can't keep john
gruden as your coach when these
emails come out what he said in these
emails how did the emails get leaked
though mike who's who's leaking this is
an nfl investigation into the washington
football team
i'm curious about that as well
well and this is a subject that makes
reporters very antsy because we don't
like it when people speculate on our
sources but dan let's be realistic do we
think that the wall street journal and
the new york times were going through
dumpsters or hacking computer systems or
developing top secret sources that they
met in parking garages and they didn't
even know who the person was no this is
something someone
wanted
to be made public this was deliberately
leaked and
peter king and i were debating this
earlier this morning not on the show
just you know back and forth how did
this get out you know it's possible
that there was some rogue employee of
the league office that decided to do
this on his or her own after seeing the
contents of the emails but if that's the
case we'd be hearing that the nfl is
dismayed that someone had violated
protocol and leaked these documents
because there's 650 000 others that are
in an underground sarcophagus never to
be seen again that's what's rubbing a
lot of people the wrong way and it's not
defending gruden it's being fair to the
fact that they managed to hide
the entirety of the washington football
team investigation they leaked the
outcome of it on the perfect possible
slow news day the thursday going into a
fourth of july long weekend by the time
we got to tuesday nobody cared anymore
how in the world they have a multi-month
more than a year investigation
and they don't even have a written
report why because they didn't want any
of that stuff to come out but now
we have an agenda we have a reason we
have a purpose and we're going to just
peel off
a couple of these pages to get what we
want while the rest of the 650 000
emails will stay secret that's not right
and i think it's time for everything to
be put out on the table so we can see
dan snyder's emails to bruce allen hmm
i wonder what's in those we can see
other people around the league who've
communicated with bruce allen maybe
people in the league office have sent
emails to bruce allen let's see all of
it you can't just see a little piece of
it it's just not fair to the story to
only share a little piece of it is there
going to be anything that has to do with
daniel snyder in the washington football
team like is this over now
well it's it's only over if the nfl
successfully turns the page like it did
in july and i was stunned
that
by the time the fourth of july weekend
came and went people weren't continuing
to pound on the table that this is wrong
we've seen these these
reports that were more than 100 pages
long with deflategate and the bounty
scandal there was all sorts of
information released the bullying
scandal with richie incognito and
jonathan martin from eight years ago and
now nothing there's no written report
there's no information that's going to
be made available but i think this
breathes life into that that's where the
league miscalculated
in using
just tiny little pieces of evidence
to get what they wanted with john gruden
and or to protect dee smith
they've opened the door
to a renewed push
to say it's only fair that we see what
dan snyder sent to bruce allen or others
it's only fair
and i i i'm hearing from so many people
who are readers and viewers who are
fired up about this it tells me that
it's not going to go away anytime soon
and i i said that john is collateral
damage because it felt like the
investigation is over here hey we can
take eyes and ears off the investigation
and we'll just put it on john gruden and
that's what i find kind of hypocritical
here you want to fire john gruden fire
john gruden but be fair to one of your
owners daniel snyder and i don't i don't
it doesn't feel like the nfl was being
fair and they weren't going to suspend
john gruden for a couple of reasons
first of all i read the personal conduct
policy very carefully on saturday i
don't know what's in there that you
could even use if he was even employed
by an nfl team but these emails that we
had become privy to were all at a time
when he wasn't working for the nfl and i
think they didn't make a move on him
directly because they knew his first
defense would be
why are you only
focusing on the emails i sent let me see
all the emails if he had some legal
proceeding against the league he'd be
entitled to all of them and see
everything and then once they're out in
the open who knows where they end up so
i think the league wanted to get mark
davis to fire him and they were going to
keep leaking emails until davis fired
gruden or until gruden walked away and
my guess is last night when they met
davis made it clear to him and this is
just kind of it's just more speculation
than anything else but i think it's it's
commonsensical
davis said hey if you don't quit i'm
going to have to fire you so bruton
chose to quit okay but why is the nfl
out to get john gruden
well
john gruden
is not the kind of guy that's going to
have a lot of friends who rush to his
defense now i know some people have but
for the most part john gruden is a guy
that the league office doesn't like and
as someone that the league office
doesn't like i can relate to that but
the thing is i don't work for the league
office and he's always complained about
something he's always been you know it
doesn't like doesn't like this rule
doesn't like this procedure openly
defied the mask requirement last year in
in the regular season games and was
fined multiple times for it he's just
become a guy that they don't like and
now they had this fall into their lap
and again it all may have started with
this idea we can save demoris smith
but then once you start looking more and
more you realize hey you know what we
also
can bring down john gruden and all it
takes is one person in a high position
of power or influence who doesn't like
somebody and if you've got the
ammunition that john gruden has given to
you through his own actions it all comes
together and the dominoes fall and john
gruden's done he's mike florio pro
football talk live co-host and of course
contributor for nbc's football night in
america career-wise what's next for john
gruden
well
he's only 58 years old so
i i don't think he ever coaches again
at the nfl level
i think it would be hard to sell him as
a college coach somewhere even if he
would have the patience to coach in
college you know he was always very good
as a broadcaster i don't know that a
network hires him but one year two years
three years i don't know but time passes
wounds heal a lot of it depends upon
what he does
to earn redemption to earn an
opportunity but you know we we've seen
people come back from all sorts of
things
and
uh you know i can't rule out anything it
all depends on what he wants to do he
may decide i'm done with this crap i'm
done i've made enough money i've reached
my limit where i can just go live my
life and i'm just going to go live my
life and leave all this crap behind me i
could see him having that attitude
i mentioned about the colts with carson
once and the number of snaps he has to
take the percentage that will move a
second-round pick to a first-round pick
conditional
if you're the colts
and you are you know five or six wins
after uh you know 12 or 13 games can you
see
an organizational tank where you have a
healthy scratch with carson wentz so you
keep that first-round draft pick
i don't think that it would be that
blatant i think carson wentz would be
injured i think that's how they would do
it i think it's a hard sell to your fan
base if you just fold the tents because
you want to keep your higher pick
although most fans would understand it
we get into the whole integrity of the
game you know every year when i see the
draft order starting to lock in i say
hey
what is the team that's got two wins
doing trying to win on the final sunday
of the season look what it did to the
giants they beat washington a couple of
years ago in a great overtime
meaningless game
and
washington got chase young instead of
the giants because of it so and the nfl
will say oh no no every game has
integrity and so i think the colts if
they did it dan it would be
more subtle than
hey we're just going to bench carson
wentz because we don't want to give the
eagles a higher pick i know you've
mentioned this before and mentioned it
recently at what point do the browns go
is odell beckham
worth it like
i they're they don't need him like
they're a running team he's not healthy
uh i think it it brings out the worst in
baker mayfield because he's always
trying to acquiesce to you know odell
beckham to keep him happy get his
touches but
do you think that odell beckham is
on the trade block or could be well i
think i think he should be i think he
should be and maybe the browns are
trying to be subtle about it and i can't
imagine otto beckham jr wanting to be
there when you consider they scored 42
points against the chargers on sunday
and he had two catches for 20 yards and
for the first time that i can remember
during his time with the browns there
was no question posed to baker mayfield
after the game about it there was no
question posed to coach kevin stefanski
about it he'd become an afterthought and
that's not what odell beckham jr wants
to be dan i think it's time for them to
get what they can and move on you didn't
even see on sunday an effort to
incorporate him into the game plan last
year stefanski would get him some
remember the game against cowboys he was
running the ball he caught a pass thrown
by jarvis lander he was really involved
they know they don't need to do that the
team has evolved past odell beckham jr
that was a john dorsey experiment they
need to find somebody else who thinks
they are a game-breaking receiver away
from being whatever it is they're trying
to be and and get the most for him and
move on it's a 14 million salary i think
it makes sense to move on but if you're
aaron rodgers and you want to find out
how much clout you have in the front
office wow is this where aaron rodgers
goes hey i want to be involved in these
uh situations you know i got randall
cobb now i want to go for the big ticket
item how about we bring in obj
that would be something i don't know the
packers cap situation off the top of my
head but again you got to absorb the
balance the 14 million dollar salary and
you can come up you can create caps but
you can wave a few magic wands and
restructure if you really want to do it
but whoever takes on otto beckham jr has
to understand that you're taking on
odell beckham jr you're taking on the
persona you're taking on the expectation
and maybe that has died down
given the injury he suffered last year
and the fact that he is basically
irrelevant in cleveland but so much of
the problem in 2019 was we got to get
the ball to obj we got to get the ball
to obj and no you throw the ball to the
guy who's open if you focus too much on
one guy
you're going to disrupt your entire
offense so it's got to be a team that
really feels like they need that number
one receiver and they already have it in
green bay and devonta adams great stuff
mike thank you we appreciate your time
thanks dan
mike florio pro football talk